and I think that the second thing that
women lie to each other about and this
kind of goes to the housewife because
for whatever reason when I have these
conversations about like what what does
it take to deserve to be a housewife we
can always like talk about it in the
abstract but when it comes to reality
it's like we could never be honest um
and the second thing I think that we lie
to each other about is just how hard
women have it I think women have it
pretty easy especially compared to men I
think you mentioned a patriarchy earlier
I don't believe in that in the slightest
I think you're given far more
opportunity as a woman your opinion bab
um and I think typically the women that
argue about patriarchy are usually just
lazy